(coups de klaxon)
le chaos règne en Haïti.
(fracas)
Le gouvernement ne contrôleono,
des gangs criminels,
qui ont pris possession de
plusieurs endroits stratégiques.
Résulat: une pénurie d'aliicici.
- Je pense qu'on peut s'asseoir
s'il vous plaît.
- Oui, merci.
- En marge du Sommetnininininin,
Justin Trudeau réunit des
représentants d'une poignée
Le ministre haïtien des
Affaires étrangères y est,
le
de même que des représentats
du Mexique, de l'Argentine,
du Mozambique et du Rwanda,
notamment.
des Affaires étrangères, Haïti
- Le pays traverse des m
très difficiles.
- Justin Trudeau annonce
trois ex-polititiens haïtiens.
Dans le groupe, unnonononom :
l'ancien président Michel
Martelly, ou Sweet Micky
sa carrière artistique.
MÉLALYLYLYLY, ministre des
Affaires étrangères, Canada
- Les personnes qui sont
directement du travail des
A A A Alors, le Canada
prend le leadership.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,dadadadadadadadaa
- Ça fait 30 ans que le Canadaet
pour aider en Haïti et
on se retrouve encore une  d d e
catastrophe humanitaire.
- Mais pas question,
pour l'instant, d'intervenir
directement sur eseseseseseseset
à jouer un rôle important,
mais nous devons avoir
un consensus haïtien.
- À que p p p p p p p p p p p p,
François Legault rencontrait
le président de la Tunisie,
un autre pays qui a attiré
l'atteKaKaKaKaKaKaKaKaKaKaKaKaKa
constitution, il a dissout
le Parlement et ordonné des
élections le 17 décembre.
lui avoir fait part
de ses préoccupations.
(applaudissements)
mememememet avec près d'une
centaine d'États c'est aussi une
occasion d'ouvrir des portes.
de la Francophonie,
Francois Legault répète
les échanges commerciaux
avec lototototototamment.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
des frères, des cousins,
çaçaçaçaçaça comme vous voulez..
Écoutez, on a peu près
5 milliards d'échanges
Comme on dit au Québec,eseseses!
- François Legault est ainsi
devenu le démarcheur en ch
ses ressources naturelles,
son électricité et sa position
stratégique comme porte d'entrée
du marché nord amériovovovovovo,
Radio-Canada, au Sommet de
la Francophonie à Djerba,
en Tuni